Congratulations. You made it to the end of the unit. What have we learned?
Well, first of all, some problems require search.
What I mean by search is you need to put together a sequence of steps,
starting from a start and keep going.
You don't know how many steps it's going to take, and you're trying to optimize some factor.
There are different kinds of search. We just scratched the surface, believe me.
It's a gigantic field with all sorts of different algorithms
and different types of applicability for these different algorithms.
There are many complications we didn't cover, but we covered two--
the shortest_path and the least_cost search.
These are two of the most useful.
Third, search is really subtle.
There are lots of possible problems lurking in there and many that we didn't even cover yet.
What that means is where there is subtlety, there is likely to be bugs,
and there are even some bugs where there is no subtlety.
That means we have to be careful.
We have these two tools for combating bugs.
One is lots of tests, and the second is standardized tools.
That is, we work really hard to make a tool that we know works
and has got all the bugs out of it, and then we reuse that tool.
Part of that reuse is generalization--
to look at a specific problem and say,
"Here we solved this specific problem this way," and to generalize it,
to say here's part of that that I think we're going to use over and over again.
Let's break that out, and now we'll have two parts to the solution.
We want to be thinking about this specific problem,
and we want to be thinking about the more general problem.
We want to be allocating our work to one or the other appropriately.
Congratulations again. You learned a lot of important concepts.
You did a great job in writing some very complex programs.